motherless Brooklyn you wrote this you
directed it you produced it you star in
it and you assembled this insane cast
an amazing cast Bruce Willis Alec
Baldwin I mean Leslie Mann Willem Dafoe
it's it's Bobby Cannavale yeah Bobby
Cannavale II you get all these people
how did you get everybody it is it is
I'm gonna just say it's one of the best
ensembles of actors I have ever worked
in and and actually it's not just that
they they did this they came in and and
played on my passion project but they
everybody did it essentially for no
money to help me underwrite the forget
to do the film I didn't have the money
to pay my buddy and everybody's starting
with Bruce right on down they did the
project for me to support me
so pretty much donated their time they
didn't know they literally they
literally financed half the film and in
that sense and and I if you see me in
something that seems beneath me for like
the next ten years it's because I'm
paying off motherless Brooklyn yeah I
want to be super clear like right in die
hard eight I will not be the villain
will be I will be like the mayor Norton
the scared mayor just before the meteor
like you'll be man in the crowd agreed